rust a memory safe compiled programming
language that delivers high-level
simplicity with low-level performance
it's a popular choice for building
systems where performance is absolutely
critical like game engines databases or
operating systems and is an excellent
choice when targeting webassembly it
started as a side project of great on
[ __ ] in 2007 who named it after the
rust fungus it was sponsored by mozilla
in 2009 and has been ranked the most
loved programming language every year
since 2016 with its fans being known as
rust stations traditionally high level
languages provide a garbage collector to
nerf your control over memory management
while lower level languages provide
functions like free and allocate to
shoot yourself in the foot rust takes a
different approach it has no garbage
collector but achieves memory safety
with a concept known as ownership and
borrowing by default every variable in
rust is immutable this allows values to
be used in the stack memory which has
minimal performance overhead however
mutable values or objects with an
unknown size at compile time are stored
in the heap memory every value in a rust
program is assigned to a single variable
known as its owner when that variable
goes out of scope the memory allocated
to it is dropped automatically in some
cases though you may want to pass a
reference to a different part of the
program borrowing allows you to access a
reference in memory without taking
ownership of it there are a ton of rules
to go along with this system that the
rus borrow checker will validate at
compile time these rules keep your code
safe while providing absolute control
over performance rust also has a package
manager called cargo where each
individual package is a crate to get
started install rest then run cargo new
from the command line in the main.rs
file you'll find a main function which
is where the program will start
executing declare a variable with let
followed by its name and type the value
can't be changed or reassigned by
default so add mutt to make it mutable
the name of the variable is the owner a
reference to its location in memory can
be borrowed by other parts of the
program by prefixing it with an
ampersand then use a macro like print
line to log the value to the standard
output rest also comes with a standard
library that contains modules to handle
io the file system concurrency among
many other things now compile your code
to an executable with the rust compiler
you just built a memory safe executable
that can handle the most performance
intensive system requirements this has
been rust in 100 seconds hit the like
button and subscribe if you want to see
more short videos like this and leave a
comment if you want to see a full rust
tutorial thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one